la saison iv l'état
me benoît 16 ans
[Musique]
en cette belle journée du patrimoine
pauline a lâché son rouleau à pâtisserie
[Musique]
je commence ma balade sur les traces de
rappeler ici à la devignère qui serait
la maison où il est né
je vais rencontrer alain lecomte qui est
le gérant des lieux et il va me raconter
plein de choses sur ce géant de la
littérature
on y va le principe de l'émission est
simple la reine du coup qui va devoir se
transformer en compagnon de carcans toi
et il ya du boulot
[Musique]
bonjour heureusement alain lecomte son
guide du jour est le spécialiste de
rabut à chanter merci de m'accueillir
sur ce très beau lieu alors on va
commencer injuste du sujet oui mais oui
c'est la devinière c'est quoi alors
devenir sait beaucoup de choses c'est
avant tout une propriété qui appartenait
à la famille rabelais
donc cette maison c'est la maison
vraiment rabelais est né alors c'est la
maison dans laquelle effectivement il
serait né de ce qu'on met toujours du
conditionnel avec rabelais est toujours
un peu insaisissable notre ami rabelais
mais en tout cas c'est la maison qui va
le marquer fortement au niveau de son
expiration il va faire de cette petite
maison le grand château des géants et il
va créer une forme d' univers à part
entière tout autour
sa part dit si donc la ligne r c'est un
petit peu le la matrice on va dire de
ses romans tout ici voilà enfin on va
apprendre plein de choses aux normes ce
[Musique]
alors là je vois un personnage qui m'est
familier oui tout à fait là ce sont les
ce sont les différents visages de
rabelais est-ce que c'est géré la
présentation de rabelais sont réels
alors il n'y a aucune représentation de
rabelais de son vivant nous ne savons
pas quoi il ressemblait véritablement
pauline et rabelais sujets sains
biographie de l'auteur élèves pauline
vous avez une heure est donc ici on dans
le pigeonnier une histoire particulière
à ceux ci alors ce pigeonnier exister
vraisemblablement du temps de rabelais a
été repris au xviie siècle donc est donc
ce pigeonnier a été transformée
aujourd'hui en musée avec énormément de
d'éléments qui permettent la
compréhension du parcours honorable m
soit rappelé les multiples c'est un mois
c'est en même temps un médecin c'est un
écrivain c'est un philosophe c'est un
penseur c'est quelqu'un qui va adopter
tous les savoirs et je dirais que tous
ces savoirs vont nourrir son oeuvre
on va continuer notre petite balade du
coup pourquoi nous connaître encore un
petit peu plus râblé l'aln je vous en
prie merci alors ces petits jardins ce
qu'il est quelque chose de particulier
alors ce petit jardin où cette vigne qui
a été planté en 2004 permet de de faire
le trait d'union entre la maison les
paysages d'inspiration c'est à dire que
vous avez devant vous tous le paysage
qui a servi à l'écriture de gargantua la
devinière une visite aux origines
tout ici inspiré le créateur de
gargantua mais heureusement pour pauline
chez rabelais littérature arrive
toujours avec les piqûres et les
fourneaux ne sont jamais loin va
inventer par exemple quelques verbes
autour de la cuisine donc le verbe
mitonné par exemple c'est de lui flat
koné oui c'est boire à boire abbaoui
voir à grands traits donc il a inscrit
également dans la langue française d
italia nisme qu'il francise donc par
exemple le cervelas le macaron le
saucisson ça viendra quand ça viendra
blinder que vivent les met dans cette
langue
d'accord et puis la vente le nom de
gastro lattre donc les adorateurs du
ventre la gastro la triste à dire
l'adoration dits modérés du de la chair
du manger parfois même dû trop manger
ces deux philosophies il avait tout
compris avec nous donne une belle leçon
vi
avec tout ça ça m'a donné faim donc on
va pouvoir à l'âge n'ont pas à les
découvrir les groupes m'ont dit on est
parti on est parti à l'est
[Musique]